our founding fathers were booze hounds
so much so that Benjamin Franklin
published a dictionary of 228 words that
all describe one thing being blind drunk
in the 13 colonies we love to drink
colonial Americans were perpetually
bombed especially since water wasn't
always clean and accessible many of our
nation's most respected men could be
found with a glass or two in hand in
fact Thomas Jefferson drafted the
Declaration of Independence while drunk
on Madeira George Washington racked up
an epic bar tab of over 160 bottles for
just 54 delegates
zone me and John Adams went on a
seven-week binge drinking six hours a
night with younger congressmen keep
drinking so Franklin took a stab at his
peers and published the terms he
overheard at local pubs in the drinkers
dictionary here's what they said I've
got corns in my head oh go eat a pudding
bag Thomas you're one to talk Washington
you're as dizzy as a goose I'm shambled
my goodness Hamilton you've got a brass
eye today well the king was his cousin
clearly gentlemen you're all wasted
mac-and-cheese
find wine and ice cream there's
something surprising they have income
and that's Thomas Jefferson Thomas
Jefferson founding father third
president and author of the Declaration
of Independence pre impressive resume
but what we should really recognize
Jefferson for is being a massive foodie
while serving as the ambassador to
France in the late 1700s he developed a
specific appreciation for all things
European while touring Europe he took
detailed notes about modern farming and
agricultural techniques upon returning
to the US he began cultivating his own
organic vegetable garden berry patch and
vineyard who even had a macaroni pasta
machine shipped over and introduced ice
cream to his kitchen after he was
elected as president he brought his
passion for food to the White House he
even served one of his favorites
macaroni and cheese at a state dinner in
1802 even though he didn't come up with
the dinner recipes himself
Jefferson helped popularize them by
serving them at decadent dinner parties
so next time you reach for your favorite
guilty pleasure say a small thanks to
Thomas Jefferson mr. president our taste
buds salute you
celebrities love endorsing presidents
and presidents love celebrity
endorsements and this is the story of
the president that started it all
Warren Harding was a 29th President of
the United States before that Harding
was a pretty generic senator the New
York Times even dubbed him faint and
colorless so how the hell did he win the
president three words
Florence clean Harding his wife and
shrewd campaigner Florence had her ear
to the ground anytime a famous or
influential person came to town she
would have them pose for a photo on
their front porch so basically the first
political selfie enter Al Jolson at the
time deemed the world's greatest
entertainer
he sang he danced he even landed the
first talking role in the movie most
importantly he became the first
celebrity to ever endorsed a
presidential candidate Harding had
several other celebrity endorsements
most notably Thomas Edison and Henry
Ford and guess what it worked
Warren Harding became our 29th president
and despite going down as one of the
worst presidents in US history is
political selfies change the landscape
forever
I have one child making the best
clothing in the world
my name is Martin Greenfield it used to
be maximilien grünfeld when I was born
but we I'd changed it to me that
American because I love this country
my craft is very difficult to define
because it's many things I am a maker of
clothing I know how to measure I know
how to fit people very few people could
match me I was responsible for all the
presidents Clinton I measured in the
White House Obama measured in the White
House so then I made imperfections we
never had to fix nothing my life is a
sad life before I came to America
because I lost my family I was left
alone everybody was there we were
occupied
ouch which was a month later I was in
the concentration camp a year in two
months I was my second day in Auschwitz
there's no more names because iteration
cap only numbers when they called me
they sent me to tailor the head they
ever spoke my language he was Jewish
they asked me are you a tailor no I said
if you could show me how to make the
color
he says I'll make you a god showed me
have my god the pain is still in my
heart about my family I still dream
about my family like they're alive but
on the outside you will never know I
didn't think I was gonna survive I was
liberated by Eisner General Eisenhower
came in when I was fifteen and a half
years old and when they worked in I
shook us in crying you saved my life
I came to America September 18 1947 they
gave me
the job as a tailor I told my boss
listen eyes never liberated me I want
you to make him a three-piece suit like
I've aired myself he liked it once he
had the first three-piece suit from then
on you didn't see Eisenhower and nothing
but three-piece suits so that's how I
started
I made sure we dressed all the
presidents with Obama first he wanted me
to copy a suit I don't copy anybody
everybody copies my suit so if he wants
me to make something I have to measure
next day he sends an email would be a
pleasure to meet you that I'm happy when
I'm at the factory my job is the most
important thing in my life quality is so
important to me because I know that's
what kept me in business and that's why
I'm here talking to you
every day I turn off on to an old
country road it's about a mile from the
president's but you can see them and
then you get up to them and you stand
next to one and you go fan these things
are huge how many people on earth can
say they've got a collection of
presidents in their backyard that you
can see from space I know there's JFK I
have 43 presidents and Ronald these guys
weigh approximately 14 to 21,000 pounds
these things are huge heart they've been
here for about three years and through
time they're starting to enjoy being out
here they've got their wildlife got a
business
the weeds are growing up it's amazing
they amaze me these statues were once a
part of a outdoor park when the original
Park had closed its doors I was asked to
destroy the president's and clean the
place off it hit me I said I'm not
destroying them I'm going to figure out
something the feeling I get from them
it's it's overwhelming these guys they
still have strength today that they had
when they were alive and forming our
country they mean a lot to me I want to
bring them back to a museum where they
can be enjoyed by everybody
fire stations big red trucks flashing
sirens that cool shiny pole well it all
dates back to colonial times and this
guy had a little something to do with it
that's right Ben Franklin most known for
the Constitution electricity and the
bifocals Ben Franklin had a weird
obsession with fire safety on a trip to
Massachusetts Franklin noticed that the
good people of Boston were much more
spire savvy than his fellow citizens in
Philadelphia hmm this got been thinking
and he came up with the idea to create a
club or society of active men belonging
to each fire engine whose business is to
attend all fires with it whenever they
happen then Ben got weird he wrote an
anonymous letter to his own newspaper as
a senior citizen titled protections of
towns from fire deer Pennsylvania
Gazette
the letter encouraged a better fire
safety plan and painted a horrifying
alternative people jumping out of
windows breaking their necks and being
burned alive but it worked
in 1736 the first American volunteer
fire department was born the Union Fire
Company it was comprised of 30
volunteers and you might know some of
them George Washington Thomas Jefferson
and Samuel Adams that's right our
founding fathers were also firefighters
soon after fire companies and clubs
sprang up all over Philadelphia and then
across the 13 colonies so thanks to the
matchless leadership of Benjamin
Franklin we now have firefighters thanks
Ben